[Music]
you are watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
coming up we'll see what's making the
headlines with the deputy online editor
of the new statesman rachel kunliff
and pr consultant alex dean and they
will both be with us through right until
midnight
for our extended news review they're
still smiling at the moment
so let's see what's on the front pages
of those newspapers for you now
with express leads on boris johnson's
warning that some
covid restrictions may need to continue
after
july the 19th that's also
on the front of the eye which says
there's hope of summer travel for those
who've been fully vaccinated
the telegraph has the pm's plea of
patience on its front page
as covert disruption in schools
continues
the mirror goes with princes william and
harry unveiling the statue of their
mother princess diana in the sunken
garden of kensington palace
it's also on the front of the metro with
the headline reunited
for diana on what would have been her
60th birthday
it also dominates the sun's front page
and together but still so far apart
that's the daily mail's take
climate change is the guardian's lead
with a scientist warning that nowhere is
safe from the kind of extreme
heat events that have hit the western
u.s and canada
and the ft reports on a global agreement
to tax multinational companies
a 15 minimum corporate tax rate
from 2023
so with me tonight rachel candler deputy
online editor of the new statesman and
the pr consultant
alex dean welcome to you both let's
start with the
i and uh freedom day can the prime
minister
deliver what has been promised the 19th
of july will it come to fruition or has
he promised
too much too soon rachel
well i think it has to go ahead uh
regardless of anything else for two
reasons one being the
backlash when it was delayed by four
weeks the first time particularly from
within the conservative party and the
prime minister's own
back benches uh given that the
the the rate of vaccinations um and
while cases are rising
the so far the the slower rise of
hospitalizations and deaths but the
other main reason it has to go ahead is
of course
matt hancock the government has lost all
its credibility
to continue to impose restrictions given
that the man who was making the
decisions about the restrictions until
very recently
was caught on camera breaking said
restrictions and i know we've got a new
health secretary
um and i know that it's a fresh new
start and we're all meant to forget
about what was the big story
uh this time last week um but it does
matter
and i think that that is why the legal
restrictions
are going to go on july the 19th
regardless of anything else because
politically there is no other option now
what the prime minister is warning of
or laying the groundwork for is some
precautions may remain
that's that's a very vague term there's
some speculation in the eye about what
that could mean
the continuation of guidance to wear
masks the continuation of
um advice that that people should keep
their distance to
to one meter possibly restrictions on
events that mean you have to show
vaccination status or a negative covert
test
um all of those are up for discussion
one thing that i think will probably be
continuing whether the government
suggested or not is continued guidance i
could do
continuing to decide to work from home
so life isn't going to go back to normal
exactly as it was 15 months ago i think
the the key distinction here is it won't
necessarily be the government mandating
that we do these things it will just be
guidelines as they say in paris
caribbean
alex do you agree that the government's
decision on whether
the 19th will continue to be freedom day
as it's been described do you think that
that will be informed by the manner in
which
matt hancock left no matt hancock paid
the price for breaking those rules with
losing his job
i think the government's decision on it
will be based on the broad criteria that
we've
all heard so much about now and on that
i agree with rachel completely that
i think the government will go ahead on
the 19th of july um the case count may
be
uh rising somewhat which was always
expected albeit
sage's forecast had it much worse than
this by now so
even on the most optimistic of
projections uh we are doing well
but moreover as rachel also mentions
we've decoupled the link yeah the link
between
um cases and hospitalizations and sadly
death that seems to have been broken so
that is tremendous
news and i think the government's going
to go ahead i do think there is a point
too about how much you can ask people to
do
and i think we are at our very limits
but remember the government asked us to
hang on for a single more month
well we've done that and i think now it
is the right time to list the
restrictions and i think you think
that's what the government's going to do
yes and rachel what's the position with
the schools the telegraphed uh
looking at the argument over bubbles
they're meant to be
um a thing of the past and actually have
children testing far more frequently so
you don't have children that are
perfectly healthy
being sent home what's the telegraph
saying on this
so let's be clear about this the
situation in schools at the moment
is a national scandal and i really think
it should probably be leading every
single front page
and i think it is much more interesting
than a statue of diana because you have
385 000 children
currently off school that's six percent
of school pupils across the country
who are off the vast majority of whom
have not tested positive themselves
they've been sent home from school
because they're in a bubble
they're in a class or they're in a group
with somebody who has tested positives
now these schools are expected to do
hybrid learning
so they're expected to teach in person
but also provide some kind of online
learning for the kids who are off
we know that teachers are not able to do
that it's two very different types of
learning
and not to mention the fact that their
parents therefore need to stay home
and look after them so we have a crisis
it is
rising the telegraph estimates that if
it continues to rise at this level and
we talk about exponential
growth then in the last week of the
summer term two million
children will be off school and the
government's response to this has been
be patient will maybe think about doing
something at some point these are
children who have already
had a year of highly disrupted
education the amount of online learning
they were able to do when schools were
closed was minimal
the most disadvantaged children didn't
even have laptops and equipment
necessary to learn at home
thanks to gavin williamson not providing
the equipment that he said
was necessary teachers have been trying
to to
to move all of their learning online
which
many teachers have spoken to me and said
it's not that simple it's not that easy
to do
the government's talking about catch-up
programs it's dedicated a tenth of the
money
that its own advisor suggested
let's just bring alex in there i mean
the the government is saying that it's
something that they're going to look at
getting rid of of uh
the bubbling um procedure but
potentially i suppose they're going to
think about this after the the summer
break
yeah well rachel's right about it being
a big problem i mean if you've got
nudging 400 000 children the vast
majority of whom don't have the
condition you're worried about
being sent home it isn't just their
education being [ __ ]
again it's also their parents who have
to scramble child care
and the impact on society and the
economy is yet greater
i think one obvious potential thing and
teachers
do hate this suggestion but is having
tests at school rather than at home
because
all too often it seems that people
aren't managing to administer the test
at home and so those few children
comparatively few children who do have
coronavirus are going to school having
not been tested
at least we might be able to nip it in
the bud at school both for those who do
have coronavirus
and moreover for those who don't who
should be able to stay
in school if they're symptomless and
test negative
they should be able to continue their
education they've suffered so much
already
if you think about the compressed nature
of child a child's life when it's such a
big percentage of their life they've
already lived
variations on lockdown and not being at
school we've got to get education back
on track again so this ought to be a
priority and i would say by the way
big credit to the telegraph who's
pursued this story consistently
uh amongst our media outlets and here it
is on the front today i think it's a
really interesting story and good for
them for running him
yes and they do say that they started uh
began the campaign calling on ministers
to put children
first um another story actually on the
front of the telegraph
we've just got time for before the break
uh tell us rachel why
five million of us um might not be able
to
to travel because of the particular type
of jab that we've had
so if you've had a version of the
astrazeneca jab that is
the ashrae zenika jab that is developed
in oxford but was made in india
then the eu's medical agency hasn't yet
approved that
and it doesn't count as part of their
new covert vaccine passport scheme
which is going to uh infuriate a high
number of brits who have had that jabs
who obviously weren't given
the option i mean there wasn't very much
choice about which dab to have out of
the major manufacturers anyway let alone
whether you had the one that was made
in the uk or made in india so a lot of
upset over this you've got to remember
though
that the eu back back when people were
being vaccinated said that the actual
job didn't work at all regardless of
where it was being made
so i think this is one instance where
the blame that is being laid at the uk
government i think very firmly west
on the on the eu shoulders were being
too slow to approve
this this vaccination which obviously
we're talking about from a british
perspective
huge consequences for the millions of
people you've been vaccinated with
across
africa and asia you're basically telling
people in some of the poorest developing
nations
oh we don't think the jab you got was
good enough or what's that going to do
for vaccine hesitancy
okay we have uh run out of time alexa
we'll come back to you i know you were
waiting but we will come back to you
after the break
do stay with us coming up together but
still so far apart the headline on the
daily mail as princes william and harry
unveil the statue of their mother
princess diane
[Music]
at the start of this we reckon that you
needed somewhere around 65
70 of the population the whole
population
to be immune in order to have that herd
immunity which prevents the virus
spreading
now since then we've got these rather
more transmissible variants
particularly the delta so maybe that
figure's
gone up to around 70 because it has a
bigger r number our zero number
um and you know therefore we have to
think about vaccinating the
kids um because eighty percent of the
adult population if that only represents
fifty percent of the whole population
we're still too low to prevent the virus
spreading and it will spread in kids so
i i'm in favor if we can and when we can
of vaccinating children as well so that
the whole population is immune
to the point where the virus can no
longer circulate um kovid will be with
us for quite a long time
we've got to get used to it we do have
outbreaks of course of other
virus infections in the winter
flu notably but also what we call
rhinoviruses common cold respiratory
insitial virus
they come around every winter and
perhaps perhaps
uh kovid will be the same it's worth
observing however that the serious
pandemics
of the 20th century 1918 57
68 etc uh which were in fact
all flew in the first wave the first
year
those viruses those pandemics were quite
severe with a lot of deaths
as they went on although those same
viruses with changes
continued to circulate they became
attenuated they were less
virulent in the population and caused
less deaths and it may be
that when we're vaccinated and we've
seen covid
before if we do get infected in the
future
it may well be that it's significantly
more mild than it has been on this first
wave of infections in the human
population
[Applause]
the enormous explosion has just come
down
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
you either live and recover or you die
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello or like we say in my language is
relay
i am tony the founder and the ceo of
renewables in africa this picture
changed my whole career
and my whole life my mission is simple
it's to bring back power
to africa and our need is to turn the
dark continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous one by
[Applause]
2014
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me tonight rachel
cunliffe and
alex dean and we are going to have a
look at the
ft now the front page there good news
for sunderland uh with that nissan
offering um a boost in terms of jobs
alex
and a billion um of investment i think
it's tremendous news and it's likely of
course to be the first such facility
for the manufacturing of new electric
cars fantastic that nissan has chosen
the uk
it would be foolish not to remember but
the good people of sunderland were
treated as if they were sort of
sub-normal for daring to do at which
they were told not to do and to vote for
brexit and we were told that nissan
would be leaving the uk
here instead they are doubling down
committing to our market i mean we're
going to be exporting these cars
and a fantastic new jobs uh with them
too
um in sunderland are going to be
exporting these cars to the continent
and elsewhere and indeed the boss of
nissan says that brexit
is an opportunity but thanks to brexit
we're moving forward i mean i thought
that was remarkable that
we've seen that kind of turnaround but
most of all what great news for the
people who are in these jobs now secured
on site already and great news for the
people who are going to have these new
jobs and the research and development
that comes with it
we're leading the way in this green
technology i think it's fantastic
rachel a vindication for brexiteers
well in some sense i mean the brexit
enabled the government to change its
rules on on state aid and subsidies
which it announced last month and and we
know that that had a bearing on nissan's
decision
as did the the 100 million pounds that
the uk government is putting into that
plant which you can say is
is great investment sure i'm just quite
surprised
to hear of a free marketeer like alex be
so positive about something uh when when
one of the main arguments brexit was
also
about competition cutting back statism
and business and allowing
companies to to sink or swim depending
on on competition
and and uh and and their own merits
didn't expect that kind of status
argument but hey if it's if
it's working and alex is happy with it
i'm happy with it the point of that
julian is that the state aid rules in
our country are now decided in
westminster and not brussels
the point of taking back control is that
you can use that control
it can't possibly be that you should
never use the control you just
reacquired is it
so last westminster is able to make
these decisions you might disagree with
it on
on stage and competition grounds and i'm
delighted to hear you're a free
marketeer now
but actually given that people around
the world support their automotive
industry in this way
i'm rather glad that these decisions are
being made in westminster with our money
rather than brussels with our money
rachel take us to the daily mail and uh
the statue unveiled of princess diana
today
there's been a statue which um is very
nice
i always think that statues that are
that realistic
of of modern people can can look
slightly jarring because we're not used
to
seeing them it's quite sweet she's got
some children they're not her children i
don't think but
you know it's very sweet and it's on the
front pages of all the papers instead of
the crisis in education which is only on
the telegraph no i understand why this
is a story this is a story because
prince william and prince harry met
and they smiled and they unveiled the
statue of their mother and it is a
chance to
revisit the rift and is the rift healing
um and
i just think it's it's kind of very sad
when you remember
that these are two men who who lost
their mother
when they were very young and if they
dealt with this in in slightly different
ways
you know who can blame them rachel and
alex thank you